[Music]
only about four thousand snow leopards
are left in the wild and that's low
enough to classify them as a vulnerable
species they roam across Central Asia
where climate change and poaching
further threaten their survival
most countries do not actively protect
these big cats but a program in the
remote mountains of Russia and Mongolia
is trying to save the local species and
it's working Elizabeth Palmer visited
the area to give us a rare look in these
remote Altai mountains in southern
Siberia three decades of hunting and
poaching had almost wiped out the Snow
Leopard in the village of GE's otter we
found Boris Markov a former poacher know
back in the day he told me just one pill
was worth a car
our journey deep into Russia's sulukim
Ski National Park took us off road and
on horseback to meet park biologist and
researcher Alexey Kuznetsov he's part of
an innovative program to bring the
leopards back by shooting them with
motion-triggered cameras hidden in the
wilderness the results are astounding
intimate shots of animals so shy they do
anything to avoid humans even Alexei has
only seen a Snow Leopard once though
there's not much he doesn't know about
their behavior like the way they scratch
to mark territory domestic cats and
here's one caught on camera doing
exactly that Sergei Kirov akov is
another ex poacher he's still got one of
the lethal wire traps used by locals but
Sergei has changed sides he's just one
of several former hunters getting a
salary through the World Wildlife Fund
to monitor the cameras when you get the
photo cards out do you look at the
pictures yourself to see what's there
no oh yes it's so interesting I check
right away to see if there are Cubs and
often there are female leopards can have
as many as four
Cobb's in a litter alexsei says that
paying the former hunters and poachers a
salary is key but there's also been a
sea change in attitude so did everybody
in the village you want to see the
photographs can use the Kodomo proximity
windows they lined up local people who'd
never seen a snow leopard before now
know how beautiful they are back at the
national park headquarters
Alexei showed us more pictures from a
hundred and twenty cameras that have
been snapping away night and day for
five years of course
Alexei has his favorites he knows every
single animal by its unique pattern of
spars this is not only a treasure trove
for scientists but thanks in part to the
photo surveillance poaching has
virtually stopped and there is very good
news in just five years the population
of the Altai snow leopards subspecies
has roughly doubled forty five so far
and Counting for CBS this morning
Elizabeth Palmer in Altai Siberia very
curious about what animal light its
their eyes what a great program - thank
you Elizabeth Palmer after them in that
sense